uh welcome back everybody uh welcome
back to the food track ER it's my
pleasure to introduce yoris bandm
probably some of you have listened about
an obscure Library named pandas perhaps
H well we're talking with the the pandas
person he's core contributor of pandas
and also Apache Arrow he works for BTR
dat and let's welcome him pretty
glad
yeah uh thanks for the introduction um
so I'm indeed a pandas um maintainer I'm
also um maintaining help maintain some
other packages including geopandas um
and I'm working at Voltron data uh
helping maintain Apache Aro and
especially the uh the python binding so
P Arrow so if you want to uh chat about
or have questions about geop Pas apach
Arrow I'm also happy to um talk with you
on those topics Beyond
pandas another um thing to mention is
that those slides are an updated version
of talks that I gave earlier this year
with um with the other pandas
maintainers Patrick Huffer and Richard
shedro panas has been growing a lot not
only the codebase but also the the
community of contributors that that yeah
essentially um creates pandas um I
created here a small plot of the number
of unique weekly committers if you if
you take a larger time slot you will
have a much bigger uh unique number
because not everyone commits uh every
every week uh but you there are some
fluctuations there is apparently a peak
during coid for some reason um and uh
but there is a yeah a trend that we have
grown a lot over the
years um to be clear this is just
commits that's the easiest proxy to
measure a bit uh Community size but
there are many other ways that you can
contribute uh beyond having uh counting
commits um but so with this growing
Community we also needed to make some
updates to how we work so historically
we have had a um benevolent dictator for
life with KY and for the rest we worked
on consensus but with a growing
community and having West moved on to
other uh projects we needed yeah some um
new ways to to make uh decisions uh
because it became um yeah unclear how
decisions are being made there are some
implicit power structures naturally uh
occurring and for larger changes we had
some examples where um yeah things were
a bit stuck to get to uh decision so we
have been working the last year uh with
the coure team to um yeah give an update
to our governance uh Also to clarify
roles and responsibilities Beyond just
uh code but also updating how we make uh
decisions and for um specifically for
technical changes uh so for larger
changes to the pandas code base that
impact users uh we have adopted uh
pandas enhancement proposals process
last year um I assume that quite some of
you might be familiar with python peps
um so it's very similar uh um ideas as
that and there are also quite some other
projects in the P ecosystem like non pyy
learn and others that use a similar uh
process so the idea of a pep is that you
um have a document that describes a
certain proposal um gives the context
the pros and cons uh possible
alternatives that helps document and
record uh um a proposal and the
discussion uh towards um a compromise on
on that um
proposal a pep itself or yeah also a pep
in general doesn't neily uh specify how
you make the final decision you still
need to decide if the pep gets accepted
or not
um for example in Python the the peps
are decided by the steering Council at
the moment we are um yeah finalizing how
we uh decide on peps in pandas and we
are currently uh discussing a v voting
mechanism among the core
developers but in the last year we
already created quite some uh peps um
some already accepted some uh in the in
the works and so the rest of uh the
remainder of this stock will mostly um
go through some of those uh PPS and I
will see how far I
get before diving into the uh more
important peps or bigger peps I want to
mention two new features that already
landed in pandas 2. uh Z which was
released uh in April of this year
related to uh time series data time
stamps um one thing uh in panas 2.0 is
that we improved the resolution of time
stamp so historically we only supported
nanc that's the internal under the hood
implementation detail how the time stamp
is stored as an inteior um as nanc and
that has a consequence that you can only
uh yeah store a very limited um range at
least limited if you want to uh go
beyond 200 years in the future or in the
past um and you get you got you got this
out of bounds day time error starting in
Bas 2.0 we uh support all resolutions
from NCS up to seconds and essentially
with that kind of resolution you can
represent any possible date in in the
history of the of the Universe
um how can you use this by default we
still use nanoseconds um also for
example date range as a way to create uh
a regular uh time series will still
create NCS but then you can cast it to
uh for example in this uh small example
2 seconds um or
if you start from a num array with a
certain resolution and you create an
pandas uh series from that you will now
preserve this uh
resolution second change that already
landed in 2.0 related to uh date times
uh is Pep 4 um and it's about parsing
daytime so if you start from string for
uh strings that represent dates for
example from a CSV file you want to
convert them to actual dat times you
need to parse those strings
and in the past if you didn't specify
explicitly the format uh in in which
your strings were um or should be pared
uh pandas under the hood was actually
looking at every string individually um
and you can get annoying situations like
this where the first string um was pared
as in um American Style with the month
first um but then the second string you
can see that's European style with the
day first because that would otherwise
be possible and is then silently pared
as uh Day first so you get inconsistent
parsing and so what we or what I also
said in in the past when I was teaching
this always specify
format it's also just faster and it's
much safer uh but to avoid this Pitfall
of this inconsistent parsing by default
uh so what uh happens now in the
released version of pandas is that if
you don't specify a format we will
actually gu a format or inir a format
from the first value um and just use
that for parsing the whole thing it
might not necessarily be the uh correct
um format so if you if you guess a
format that doesn't work for all your
time stamps we will raise an informative
error message saying that you can either
specify the format or some other options
uh but at least we do will not par by
default uh use this inconsistent uh
parsing so that's already included in
pandas uh
2.0 then um I want to move to one of the
bigger and and exciting changes that are
coming to pandas and that's related to
copy and view uh
semantics I suppose that many of you if
you use pandas somewhat triggly uh will
have seen this uh dreaded setting with
copy warning
um the example that that that I uh the
code example that I used here we have a
data frame I create a subset of the data
frame by filtering some rows and then I
modify that subset and you get this
warning and the reason that you get this
warning is because pandas um isn't sure
what you it's a bit ambiguous what you
mean depending on whether you know that
subset is a copy or a
view taking a step back so what are
copies and
Views here in the example you have a
data frame one and the data frame two
and on the left side you see that data
Frame
2 uh is a um a view um and that means
that both data frame one and data frame
two actually share the same memory under
the hood while the second case you have
the same data frame one and data Frame 2
but now they data Frame 2 is a copy and
has its own memory and that means if you
modify
data Frame 2 for example in the case of
the view it will also have modified data
frame one while in the case the copy it
wouldn't have modified data frame one
and so to know when um if you do a
modification to a data frame if it would
also alter other data frames you need to
be aware of this uh um copy and View and
know when something is copy and when
something is view um and because that's
quite hard to know that gets confusing
and that's the reason that this warning
uh
exists how do people typically solve
this warning at the moment um is that
either you wanted to update your
original data frame then you can do that
on one line um um which uh one option
that is often used is through chain
assignment so the only pit file here is
that with chain assignment if you would
first do your row selection with the
Boolean mask and then the column and
then assign something that actually
doesn't work because this creates a copy
in the middle um while the second line
where you switch the order that does
work because it the first get item of a
column creates a view um now those
change assignments are generally uh
certainly discouraged because of those
pit files and the uh recommended way
that you can modify a data frame uh for
an operation like this is to use dolog
where you can specify both the row
selection and the column selection in
one
go another way that you typically see um
people deal with this warning is if you
don't care about updating the original
data frame you just wanted to work with
your subset so you can add an explicit
copy um and then pandas wouldn't warn
one problem is in this case that copy is
actually not needed and you get an
unnecessary additional copy because
subset was already a copy uh in case of
a Boolean
mask so that brings us to a current
situation where uh we think it's quite
confusing you need to be aware of those
details of copies and of views in numai
and how those rules are then a bit
different in pandas um there WI a a huge
amount of questions and blog post online
explaining this and how to deal with it
um and in addition a lot of defensive uh
and unnecessary copying happens to avoid
uh those issues so can we do better and
that's uh we think so and that's what
the copy on right proposal um uh
explains or or uh puts forward is that
we want to simplify the rule on how uh
in for those uh kind of uh operation so
that simply any data frame or series
object that is is derived from another
data frame or series through an index
operation or through a methods always
behaves as a
copy very importantly it behaves as a
copy so towards the user it behaves as a
copy and I will later explain that
internally we uh don't always use a copy
but so it behaves as a copy and that
means that if you mutate a data frame or
a series so with a set item operations
as I showed in some of the examples
before it will only change that data
frame in series and never one another
object so that also means if you want to
update if it's your goal to update and
and mutate a certain data frame or
series you can only do that by directly
uh mutating that data
frame
um we think that this is a simpler Rule
and more easy to apply and and to reason
about so if we go back to our original
example where I had a data frame I take
a subset with a Boolean mask I modifi my
subset and the question is was the
original data frame modified the answer
is now simply no because um subset is a
different object DF and subset are
different python objects and so
modifying subset will never modify DF
and this rule applies now however um the
subset was created in this case subset
was a Boolean mask that creates a copy
but if I would have used a slice in the
that uses a view and so uh that would
have had different rules in the past
with this proposal it's always the
same because it's no longer ambiguous
when something is a copy or something is
a view um we also no longer need this
setting with copy warning so we can get
rid of that warning um we using the
example where I had the data frame and I
wanted to update uh the data frame I
showed you two ways that you could do
that with a chained uh assignment where
one worked and the other doesn't didn't
work now with this
proposal um neither of them will work
because you always create under the hood
a temporary object with the first uh so
the first uh get item here this returns
a new object and then on that new object
you're are modifying something and so
that's a new object and the rule is uh
if you modify some object it never
modifies another so that has the the
consequence that change assignment never
works the recommended way with log as I
showed before that still works of course
um but because this never works we don't
need a setting with copy warning um we
are aware that this kind of changes
assignment is used a lot although not
recommended but it's used a lot um and
so we will detect that you try to do
this chain assignment um and in that
case raise a warning that yeah what
you're doing doesn't work you might
think yeah but now we have another
warning the the main thing is that this
warning if you see that warning it's
always because you do something wrong
and you need to update your code so once
you did that you will never see this
warning in contrast to the current
setting with copy warning um so this
rning is really there to help you update
uh your code for uh those changes
one other thing um
so we also no longer need this uh
defensive
copying um going back to uh the example
where I added a copy to avoid the
warning so now you can just leave out
that copy so in the future you don't
need that copy anymore to avoid a
warning um and and that avoids yeah
adding a lot of copy and defensive
copying uh in in your codes
that's in user code but more uh maybe
even more importantly also in pandas we
can avoid many of those copies um I
mentioned before it behaves as a copy so
whether we copy or not becomes an
internal implementation detail and we
can in many operations uh avoid the copy
delay the copy of data only until you
actually want to modify something
because in many operations many
pipelines you actually don't you do a
lot of op ations you derive some data
you don't always modify um your data
frame that's more rare than doing
operations that that uh derive something
new um so to illustrate the benefit of
that uh I created here a small uh
Benchmark toy data Frame 2 million rows
30 columns mix of some data types quite
typical uh data set I think and I do
some operations uh rename some columns
add some new columns drop some columns
uh cast the column to a new data type
reset the index set the
index um a bunch of nice meta chain uh
and currently that takes 2.4 seconds
mostly because it actually copies the
whole data frame in every single step um
with if we enable copy on right it now
takes in the milliseconds because we
don't need to do those copies anymore
and many of those operations except for
the casting actually only modify some
metadata about your data frame so how do
you try this um it's already implemented
it's already available in panas it's
only not yet a default you can already
try it out on your code Base by using
this option the options. mode. copy and
WR seta to True um and we really
encourage you to try it out we hope and
expect that it becomes default behavior
in pandas 3.0 which is planned for next
year um and there are some links here as
well with more uh information about
it switching to a second uh important
upcoming change uh and that's described
or was proposed in pep 10 which has been
accepted um and that's about string
data currently if you create a series or
you read data from somewhere and you
have string
data you will see this as object DET
type and I assume that most people um
using pandas regularly know yeah if I
have object D type most likely that are
strings but you're actually not 100%
sure uh that it are strings we want to
have a proper string data type and so uh
this proposal
um has has been accepted to actually do
that that in the future we have an
actual string data type so if you you
create strings or read data from
somewhere and you have a column of
strings it will actually have a string
uh data type where you're sure you only
have strings
um under the hood we are going to use py
arrow for this because py Arrow has a
very efficient implementation for um to
represent strings an array of variable
link strings and also has a lot of
operations um compute operations
implemented efficiently so this gives a
significant performance Improvement
because of no longer using an object
array with python objects where we Loop
through to do the operations um and at
the same time also having a smaller
memory footprint while being almost
exactly uh compatible with the current
uh implementation there are always some
small Corner cases we got a buck report
in P Arrow where the capital um
character of some special ger
German
supports but you can get a nice speed up
by specifying the the arrow uh engine I
will skip this part um to quickly show a
few last
peps pep 6 is one that is also already
uh accepted uh and that's about if you
do a set item operation how yeah the D
types are handled the example here shows
if you that so you have a data frame and
you have an interior column and in that
column you're trying to set a float or
you're trying to set a string and what
happens
um does it truncate like round the flow
to an INT or does it convert the
Interiors to floats to set it um or does
it raise an error it's not very clear I
think we generally upcast um but it also
means that you silently by setting the
string three you silently upcast to
object D type um and so what the
proposal says we don't want to guess
what should happen and set item
operations in the future will
essentially never change your data type
Ty um and so the cases where it
currently changes your data type will in
the future raise an error and first a
warning um if you actually want to set a
string and you want to have a
combination of interiors and strings in
your column you can still always uh cast
your column to object data type first
and then we are happy to allow setting a
string in that in that
column one other thing uh to which is
under discussion and it will also impact
quite some people I think um because
unfortunately although the in place
keyword doesn't do often most of the
time it doesn't do much uh it's used
quite a lot uh but so there is a
proposal to deprecate the keyword and
eventually after a deprecation period
remove it um in most places where it
exists uh there are some methods such as
fil that can actually do something in
place where we will keep it
uh but for this example where you do a
reset index with in place equals
true under the hood it's actually doing
exactly the same as as this like man
assigning to the same variable uh so
it's really just syntactic sugar
for assigning to the same variable and
we have the feeling that it's not worth
to keep it for that reason it's actually
not for this example it's actually not
shorter um and um it also introduced a
lot of confusion because people think
that things are faster when it's not the
case uh and so we want to simplify uh
this and and and uh remove the in place
keyword to end
um the panas 2.1 uh was released two
weeks ago so some of the things that I
explained here are available as
experimental features there there some
other um highlights of the release that
I don't have time to uh mention anymore
but um I want to finish this talk with
uh saying that although I'm here
explaining many of those things that are
coming to pandas it's of course not at
all my work or my work alone
um that's the work of a whole Community
um of contributors and you can also
become part of this community and the
first opportunity to do so there is a
print on Saturday afternoon uh and you
can um start or continue to contribute
to pandas during that
um
Sprint thank
you